and i also loved their throat to you
julie the january 6 oh oh the police
opened the door and let people walk in
the building terrorism
yeah they got a strong definition don't
they and when protesters like literally
broke down the barriers in front of the
white house and were setting fire to the
church across the street from it that
was not an insurrection that was not
terrorism the president of the united
states had to be hidden away in a
shelter but that was not terrorism or an
attempt at an insurrection
right
well in here it's not just reddit
posters or whack jobs who are randomly
saying that this is terror you have our
fbi director christopher wray who is
designated january 6 as an act of
domestic terror they are comparing
january 6 defendants to terrorists
and so when you have this codified by
your top law enforcement official then
of course that is how it goes mainstream
so you have democratic lawmakers or even
judges just
just say well they were terrorists this
was a terrorist attack and these people
are terrorists so then it everybody
becomes a terrorist right except for the
actual terrorists you know the people
who burn down cities and to your point
two billion dollars in damages um the
fbi has arrested three times as many
people related to january 6 and they
have the entirety of 2020 rioting which
is insane um and you have that you have
chris ray still lying about it saying oh
we're handling both events equally
when we can't read and we can't pay
attention to actually what's happening
just just think about that for a couple
seconds
you have people who caused when we say
two billion dollars in damages that's
the maximum the insurance companies
would would pay out it's not even the
total amount damage could be way higher
when you have estimates ranging from
like 26 to 32 dead in these riots
they they they burnt down a police
station and the police were forced to
flee
for three months they were fire bombing
a federal courthouse
and there there's no terror declaration
there's no law enforcement there's
stopping dismissing charges against
those people they've already dismissed
about a third of the charges related to
portland just think about that for two
seconds and then you have you know the
magama types who went to the capitol and
the police removed the barricades the
police did that and you see one cop
fanning people
they walk in now there was conflict at
the tunnel people were fighting and we
have we had richie mcginnis on the show
he's a journalist who was there people
were shoving with cops and fighting with
them yelling stuff yeah but then you
have people who are walking up to a door
the police open the door and one cop can
be heard saying i don't agree with it
but i agree with you right to protest as
they all come in walking and bumbling
about the magami mimo types they're the
terrorists
madison cawthorne spoke at a rally for
president trump far away from you know
relatively far away and they're claiming
he was supporting he was involved in the
insurrection
and the media is on on board and the law
enforcement our law enforcement address
is on board when you have
these two very clean very two distinct
circumstances
you need to start realizing that they're
at war with you
that they want to destroy your life and
what i mean by that i mean like there
are elements in the fbi not every single
person obviously but you look at the
political landscape there are there are
powerful connections between media and
democrats and i'm not speculating we've
got the cnn story where the woman who
worked for andrew cuomo then went became
chief marketing officer at cnn and was
hooking up with the president and that
whole scandal happens they're obviously
colluding in big tech as well and they
want to ruin your life they hate you
and you just have the news this week
that a top national news editor at the
washington post has to recuse herself
from her job from her position because
she's married to the chief of staff to
the fbi director chris wray
so think about i mean so the
incestuousness
so you have a major newspaper who has
lied about russiagate for years and now
is covering up huge stories like the
whitmer kidnapping fbi kidnapping plot
and certainly has a huge spin on what
happened you know ray epps that's a
conspiracy theory this is the washington
post and then you find out here is she
is married a top editor married to the
chief of staff the fbi
matea gold so this was a great paul
sperry uh a piece investigative piece on
real clear investigations and he details
the whole thing and this man's father is
tied to the clinton machine like it just
you you know it just
it's a big club and you ain't in it
that's for sure right you don't want to
be right
at the same time
once they get you in they want to keep
you in that's why i don't want to get in
well they have to do it from outside
they're losing
they're they're losing yeah people don't
act this way if they're winning
people act this way power when they're
losing the desperation that's right like
raiding james okay the fbi raid on james
o'keefe i'm just like wow you got to be
really desperate to pull a move like
that you do and i mean i think that
that's one thing that our side or
whoever side needs to realize and i talk
with this like people are friendly smith
um when you are a political party and
you're in charge you don't act this way
if you are winning over the masses if
you're convincing them um you know even
30 years ago if you're a bill clinton
and you're charming and you're trying to
actually bring people together at least
one office but this is the this is
actually the last gasp of the left of
the radical left they are they're
desperate and this is why they are
calling people terrorists that's why
they're rounding up
indiana mimas you know this is why
the media is so corrupt and they're
i mean it's all falling apart for them
they think that they're convincing us
that they're winning but they're
actually losing and so that's why
they're it's it's going to get worse
before it gets better i've i've heard
that a lot meemaw like what is what does
that mean
like it
well i mean there were older women there
um one indiana grandma the mima who went
through the re-education camp from her
court-appointed uh radical left uh
attorney and um you know she was a
grandmother of five but there were
elderly older not elderly you know 60
some odd-year-old women who were also
raided by the fbi and charged with
misdemeanors so that's sort of the joke
but there were just average americans
and they were it was very offensive for
those people to be in the capitol
building no i was thinking about this
2023 is primary season
donald trump presidential primary season
donald trump is already campaigning he's
already got that viral video where he's
like i'm going to be the 45th and 47th
president
and so we know what that is like if you
were to ask me i'd say they planned that
because he wanted people to know he's
running he wants the funds the donations
the interest but he doesn't want to
publicly announce he is it's very clever
or maybe it really was just him and
somebody's were golfing and he and he
said it you know because he wasn't he
didn't care
but this means
if joe biden is not going to be running
for re-election and i don't think he
will be
we'll have to hear something in the next
six or so months
because
for donald trump to already be gearing
up and he's doing his campaigns he's got
122 122 million the democrats need to
start raising money
if joe biden is going to run for
re-election he needs to start gearing up
now but he's not
they they're i don't think joe biden can
win again people hate him his approval
rating is in the gutter we what was that
what was the jobs report minus 300 000
minus
did that happen during the lockdowns
wasn't that like when everything shut
down it was like yeah that kind of
figure that's a scary bad but my point
is if if if if it is true that joe biden
will not be running for re-election i
think by like june we're going to hear
an announcement if something's going to
happen
yep
joe biden
joe biden raised 1.69 billion dollars
for his
re-election or his election campaign
last year is that correct no no no no
you i'm sorry i have to correct you joe
biden and the dnc it's it's instantly
it's um
joe biden
didn't raise the money anti-trump raised
them yeah but okay so he won 1.7 billion
dollars and the dude sat in his basement
and didn't
yeah what was his campaign does that
include all the in-kind donations
billions from big tech who were
censoring everyone and probably not
that's scandalous so what does this
money go for trump raised 1.96 billion
dollars i he was at least out there
running around doing stuff
[Music]
julie does this strike you anything
could it possibly be anything other than
political warfare and how bad do you
think it's going to get before the
election with that january 6th all
together i think it's going to get worse
everything around it yeah all of this
stuff yeah i mean i think it is going to
get worse i think it's going to get
worse in two ways they're going to
ratchet this up you already see the
january 6 committee they're desperate
they know their their their time is is
running down as well right their months
are numbered because they're going to
lose the house right so they're going to
do whatever they can they're going to
issue a report um probably two reports
one is that both that will deal with the
insurrectionist lawmakers
they're going to try to
suggest new legislation that will deal
with lawmakers who act insurrectiony in
the future
but also they're going to tie this to
election uh integrity reform and so this
has been the basis of january 6 since
the very beginning to tie anyone who
wanted election integrity to tighten up
the rules that would happen in 2020 to
that's the report that's that's the
excuse of january 6. well then we need
all these reforms so this never happens
again that sort of thing but it's also
going to get worse i'm sorry it's going
to get worse because the american people
are going to find out exactly what the
government did
government actors agencies political
actors who helped orchestrate what
happened that day and execute it and
that is going to be mind-blowing to a
lot of americans so the democrats are
losing so much support right their
popularity is dropping so much they're
not going to be able to pass any of this
stuff they're going to try but they're
spinning their wheels
but then they'll just have it out there
right so it'll just be out there these
reports it'll be like the mueller report
they're still talking about the mueller
report they want it unredacted like what
do you what it's over but
but you have insane people on the left
you have millions of those people i mean
they still actually think that trump
colluded with russia right i mean you
could tell them anything they still
think that the covington kid
disrespected the elder and you know he
should be in prison or something
yeah you know the it's not just the left
the the political ruling class or the
media it's their followers it is their
it's millions of our countrymen who have
completely lost their minds and they
would be happy
not just to have the january sixers in
prison political prison
but all of us they i mean this is what
kovit exposed coveted tyranny it's what
the 2020 and it's certainly what january
6 is you have americans who want this to
happen
so let me ask you
you seem to believe that it is going to
come out how deeply involved the state
was with uh january 6th how do you think
the american people are going to respond
to this and what do you think the
government's response to their response
will be that's a great question because
a lot of people say well who cares you
know you're going to have half of the
country who is going to believe from the
beginning it was an insurrection incited
by donald trump but you are still going
to have americans and i think this is
sort of the whole ray ups thing that
that has sort of raised a lot of red
flags for people
who is he why hasn't he been charged why
won't the fbi or mayor garland answer
who he is
so that's raised a lot of questions but
um the government's involvement was deep
and it lasted for months
ahead of time um you had something
called the fbi operation cold snap which
was launched in the spring of 2020 to
infiltrate militia groups who are
planning these anti-lock down rallies so
a lot of it goes back to lockdowns
they had informants in these militia
groups we know that for a fact and
they were responsible for concocting and
executing just like the whitmer
kidnapping probe uh most of what we saw
on january 6th not just the government
dc metro police capitol police muriel
bowser's administration
it was a lot of of independent factors
which is why they kept the capital uh
intentionally insecure that day because
they didn't want thousands of national
guardsmen there saying hey why are you
throwing flashbangs into the crowd you
know why are you shooting rubber bullets
at people outside
why why don't we go inside why don't we
put up the barricades why don't we close
the doors if you don't want them
so
that that is why
i didn't have them there i think the
propaganda's failed
you know i think what we what we saw
with joe biden's uh collapse in
popularity after afghanistan what we saw
with you know the the ongoing joe rogan
you know attempt to censor and
everything it's just not working
and i think regular people
they're just not falling for it anymore
especially like we we read that post
from the lock down critical left saying
like why isn't the left supporting the
worker uprising the message is getting
out they can't control it anymore i mean
cnn msnbc their ratings are just abysmal
people don't care they're not listening
they've lost what mika brzezinski said
they've lost the ability to control tell
people what to think
you guys remember when you said that
yeah she was like you know he thinks
he's going to tell people what to think
but that's our job that's economic so
economic hitband hitman wargaming here
that means that that's the first stage
where they're trying to bribe if the if
they think their propaganda is not
working anymore that means that their
bribes have failed now they're going to
go to stage two which is assassin
assassination see like
personnel not personality assassinations
but like uh what do you call whether the
characteristics of character
assassinations absolutely imprisonment
uh against people's will on judiciously
with the patriot act stuff like that
we're in that stage you guys got to
understand how easy it is
to to carry out so so uh let me let me
slow down start over
there was they used to governments all
over the world assassinate i mean it's
world war one and stuff like that we we
know assassinations happen but when it
came to popular uprisings there was a
fear that you would make a martyr
and so you know if you read a lot of the
history books okay so we so we have to
character assassinate we have to make
them not worthy of being heroes
but these days man i mean first of all
there's that story i don't i don't know
how true this is but i remember reading
some reddit meme about the cia's heart
attack gun you ever hear about that oh
yeah yeah it fired like a frozen
like a dart with like a frozen poison
that like when it dissolved would just
kill you and look like a heart attack or
whatever they testified under oath about
that actually yeah it's very very easy
to
assassinate
and and get away with it it's it's
ridiculously easy people don't
understand this they they think we live
in this world where like oh they would
be able to do that we'll pull it off
it's like dude they find a homeless guy
they give a weapon and they just send
him off on his way you know what i mean
it it does raise flags though real
assassinations which is why they go with
the characters and why there's
indefinite detention against like where
people can't even like speak out they're
in solitary so you don't even know
they're being detained this is this is
why i bring this up because the they've
lost control of the narrative that
freaks me out if they like what if what
will they do next look at they try to
regain control drone bombs over cities
like that's the third stage of economics
when you have full scale yeah but
they're not going to do that against
their own i don't think so but you never
think the government's going to do that
against their own system you never think
okay let me let me make my point
they need you to work to produce things
for the system which they want to
control it's like if somebody wants to
own a house they're not going to blow it
up because they can't have it a crazy
person would and maybe they're crazy
people in government but the idea is how
can we take control of this resource we
don't want to destroy it they're willing
to tolerate some loss
but my point is they've lost control the
narrative so
you know maybe
powerful people and i'm not saying the
grand conspiracies or anything i'm just
saying powerful people get mad and they
they they can be
dangerous they have a military bases all
over the earth and they're afraid of
losing it to china the hegemony to go to
the power to china so they're
desperately trying to crack down on
american descent to maintain the global
military autocracy i do not agree yeah i
don't think they're worried
at all i know they're like china yeah
who do we have on who talked about joe
biden's you know cabinet
i think no no no no well we just had him
on yeah yeah yes he did talk about you
know but in china but we had we had
someone on um a while ago talking about
joe biden's
cabinet has somebody who is very very
pro china and pro trade with china and
all the stuff and if you look back at
like the clint administration there's
all of those ties and all those
connections
yeah
so
okay
well i do believe that there's a global
movement to unify everything under like
a socio-communist
kind of um corporate
yeah
let's figure out the acronym for that i
think that there are people that with
american nationalists that are afraid of
losing american control of the global
military force i could be wrong about
that i feel like people are
desperate to maintain control
i'd like to ask you one more question um
just about uh you sort of got into what
you think the government's role in this
is when people start to recognize that
how do you think they're going to
respond to people recognizing it i think
we're in a position now let's say this
was five years ago or
maybe even ten no one would i think
accept that the government was capable
of doing this
that the fbi the intelligence community
the national security state that okay
they'll screw around with people but
they're not going to actually have this
full-scale operation to shut down what
happened on january 6 and then use that
to weaponize
all of the tools of war against american
citizens i do think and i think it does
play into the kova tyranny that people
are recognizing
that our government is run not just
political leaders but the people who
populate these agencies the nameless
faceless i mean they're anthony fouches
but there's thousands of them
who are willing to do anything they know
that they can get away with it they
don't care about your kids they actually
want your kids punished they don't care
about your business
they don't care about your future they
will do anything to keep a hold of power
and to get rid of not just threats like
donald trump or his family his cabinet
members but even his 75 million voters
so i do think that people are going to
be shocked when there's more information
that the information already is coming
out in these trials this is why they've
kind of delayed these trials this is why
they're keeping a lot of these men held
behind bars because they don't want them
telling their story
um but you can't do that forever right
we learn from russiagate we've also
learned from kovid they can only get
away with fooling people concealing
evidence getting their narrative out
there for so long before it just
crumbles and then everyone goes oh wait
a minute this was all
bs to begin with and it was we had
really bad people in charge of it yes
absolutely i think one key difference
here and i'm glad you mentioned
russiagate because for me that was
really the red pill with respect to the
deep state before that if someone
claimed that the deep state or that
there was a deep state it was colluding
against the sitting president i would
have said that sounds a little bit crazy
sheamus
you're crossing anti-semite point oh
that's right it's an anti-semitic point
of no return
how are you getting back down so so if
you believe
that there is a deep state you're right
administrators and and people who work
in government who are there
throughout various administrations and
exert influence you may be right
according to this researcher you believe
in an anti-semitic conspiracy well she
and she does research on tick tock so
it's very important of course yeah but
uh no i mean it's it's true and this
that was a big red bull moment but the
difference here is that with the
russiagate
scenario they were going specifically
after people who were acting within the
political system but with january 6th
they're going after ordinary civilians
so i'm curious about what the fallout is
going to be here because with russiagate
they just stopped talking about it and
it disappeared i wonder if it's going to
be more difficult for them to get away
with that given your average person
feels more threatened by what they've
just done here right well they the the
feds raided some random woman's home
remember that do you know about that
they've rated hundreds of people's home
but yes they were
totally totally uninvolved people well
they were there but they had the wrong
person right right right right but i
mean they're rating people they're doing
military-style fbi raids with armed
agents pre-dawn raids with military swat
teams they have trucks with battering
rams they're not they're by they're
aiming rifles at children they're aiming
them at elderly women they've dragged a
disabled veteran thomas caldwell through
the snow
and handcuffed him i mean the stories of
what this fbi has done and
it's so it's not just the top of the fbi
right it's throughout it's every single
day
56 field offices have been involved in
this and they are arresting people every
single week they're trying to get to and
my predict my prediction is they're
trying to get to a thousand defendants
by the middle of the summer so this
could be the democrats huge talking
point but to your point shamus this is
ruining people's lives and it's not just
the family that it happens to what their
whole neighborhood knows their company
you know their co-workers know their
church knows everyone sees this it is a
war on terror not just
um how the uh tools of government uh
authority are being used but it's also a
message to everyone you know you dissent
this is gonna happen to you yep this is
it's it's sounds so similar to the start
of like the bolshevik revolution or you
know the rise of the soviet union
these are the stories that i was told by
my friends who grew up in uh as children
in you know communism
and the stories they were told by their
parents about how
peop you know
it got to the point where if you said
one bad thing about the party or the
government you were taken away
we're not there come yet we still have
shows like this
but we often talk about when we compare
things to history
at what point did people say it's time
to leave germany or or spain for that
matter spain often gets left out of
these conversations a spanish civil war
communists fighting fascists and then
you get military rule for like
generations
at what point do you leave
what do you do
so many people thought it couldn't
happen here and they stayed in their
countries and they paid the ultimate
price mm-hmm
you know and i think so i'm telling you
to leave shame no i know you're always
dropping things
no but i think i think it's not just
about people it's not just about people
leaving it it's it's about people
the people who stay knowing when it's
it's time to fight to stand up for their
country and to say
this is wrong we're going to speak out
against you we're going to resist it we
got going for us here is that we're not
coming out of a monarchy like the the
bolsheviks were the russian revolution
was fighting against a monarchy so they
didn't have much choice but to fight
with physical arms we have a democratic
process of free speech and
things like that in place that can
protect our ability to diplomatically
coerce the system
and you're right and that's why i think
one of the reasons they're they're
scared losing narrative control means
that this this upcoming election is
panic mode for the establishment it's
mostly democrats it is many republicans
because the populist you know surge in
the republican party is not something
the establishment wants
but to your point julie what you're
saying about how they're ramping things
up for the summer because they're
worried if they lose the house and the
senate
they're not just going to lose the house
in the senate to republicans they're
going to lose the house and sen house
and the senate to republicans like lily
tang williams
who is like this country is becoming
communist and we have to stop it or
marjorie taylor green or lauren yes
wouldn't that be great and and that's
right
and and that's what they're terrified of
because it's actually happening but we
still have a very weak republican
leadership in the house and senate and
people are very afraid even when they
take over that this current leadership
will not be capable or willing to do to
turn the j6 committee 180 degrees and
aim it at the people who have
perpetrated this they don't want to
expose it it's the same thing a lot of
this goes back to russia gate because
how he got here is that nobody was held
accountable for what happened in russia
gate except for like michael sussman
like big deal he and you've got brain
gate and you came yeah oh no we've got
the vinman's you know now he's suing
trump and he's like on cnn and so is his
wife um no one's held accountable so
it just got worse and worse and worse
and so i say we went four years from the
fbi ambushing mike flynn
in the uh white house to ambushing the
hubers you know ambushing veterans in
their in their homes it only took four
years but why because no one was held
criminally
responsible for what they did which was
perpetrate the biggest political fraud
in american history up until january 6th
um and and
everybody's off so far you know we've
got some drip drips out of the durham
investigation but
where is that going to go well maybe
there's going to be a big surge in in
november
but not just that it's the state
elections the governorships as well and
we are very very close to a convention
of states the state-level republicans
are very very different from the federal
republican leadership so that could be
something big some people have said it's
a bad idea a lot of people are saying
convention of states is a good idea
because in the states can just take the
power change constitution and make big
moves
but i think the establishment knows that
our processes the processes that were
set up by the founding fathers work and
can save us well they're not working now
i mean that's for sure especially i mean
there's been no oversight i mean there
has not been but i just interrupt i i
disagree
i think the issue is that culturally no
one's been willing to stand up and use
what's been given to us because they've
been too comfortable and complacent but
now that things have gotten this bad and
the narrative has been shattered there
are mechanisms in place that even the
establishment can't stop
i hope that you're right i'm a little
more skeptical about that because i've
seen i see firsthand how um
you know no everyone basically has been
silent in the face of what's happening
with january 6 you're talking about not
just
the the political end of it in congress
you have this illegitimate committee
issuing subpoenas and they're working
hand in hand with the doj for contempt
of congress charges um etc you have joe
biden for the first time ever u.s
president has denied executive privilege
to his predecessor he did it twice he
did it based on the fact that january 6
was so unprecedented and it went all the
way to the courts and what did the
supreme court do
okay we're upholding it so you have
district you have district judges
circuit judges and now the supreme court
who's going along with the left because
they're afraid so there has been no
oversight in the legislative branch of
the executive branch none and it has to
but they if they take over they have to
make sure they do it this time because
they haven't done it what has to happen
is people need to primary all of these
establishments republican types and
bring in more people like marjorie
taylor green i absolutely agree i mean i
wish we had you know 230 of her that
because she actually will do it and she
feels passionate about it um but
there's still a fear factor there and
i'm afraid that if the republicans do
take the house the senate is useless the
senate's not gonna you could have a
hundred republican senators they're not
gonna do anything because they're all
basically lindsey graham or mitt romney
they are
um so it has to happen in the house
and they have to do the same thing they
have to go and zero out
they have to zero out doj's budget you
have to zero out the fbi we are zeroing
you out until we you are done we you're
done taking these we're the trials are
over we're not paying for any more
prosecutors we're not paying for any
more arrests we're not do no more
subpoenas to big tech you're done with
this will they do it
you have to do something that drastic if
people go out and vote in the primaries
go out and vote locally and make sure
establishment politicians don't win
then yeah it's going to be it's going to
be crazy um it's not going to be the
apocalypse that'll be if trump wins
again in 2024 because he's going to be
off the leash
but if
if if populist
pro-america types win their primaries
and then the republicans take the house
and you get a large portion of the house
republicans as people who say we're done
with this and it's time to go on the
offensive for once
then you're going to see some pushback
you're going to see i think the
establishment plan january 6 done
i think you're going to see republicans
making a bunch of moves of their
subpoena power but it only happens if
people go out and vote in primaries
primaries primaries primaries amen
i mean it's true it's such a disaster
only
our current republican leadership could
fail
to turn the fact that the deep state has
literally targeted their own
constituents into a political advantage
it's insane
and you're going to watch republicans in
a few weeks they are going to continue
the funding of the government the same
government that is turning
the weapons of war against their own
constituents and that exactly perfect
example the congress including most
republicans just voted last year to give
capital police 2 billion more dollars
what did capital police do they turned
around they opened up an intelligence
unit for the capitol police you know the
guys who like make sure you put your
purse through the scanner or tell you oh
the capital is that way and there's you
know cannon office building all of a
sudden they're like they have a bunch of
spies in this office and they're not
only spying on lawmakers their staff
they're spying on their donors they're
compiling dossiers well why are they
doing that for the same thing they did
in russiagate ukraine gate name it they
they have the authority to do it they're
unchecked they're unaccountable and
they're going to leak that information
to the press right so all of a sudden
this summer you're going to see terrible
stories coming out sourced to anonymous
intelligence officials which happens to
be this capitol police
intelligence unit that republicans voted
to fund yep it they don't they never
learn thanks for checking out this
segment from the tim cast irl podcast if
you want to watch live you can check out
this channel monday through friday at 8
00 pm and don't forget to smash that
like button subscribe to this channel
and if you want more unfiltered and
uncensored content with all of these
guests go to timcast.com and become a
member all of these guests you know and
love in exclusive segments on our
website where we are unrestricted in
what we talk about so you'll definitely
not want to miss it thanks for hanging
out we'll see you all next time
you